so this is what I've come up with I have
the modal's HTML inside the body of our
page it has its own unique ID which in
this case is project one it's got its
own label which is favorite app page and
then inside modal body we have some
custom content including an image and a
big block of text at the very bottom
we've got a button here that will close
our modal scrolling up we see that for
the image for the same favorite app
project we've got a new attribute called
data toggle and it's equal to modal and
the target is of course project 1 put it
all together and we get to come to our
page click on the kitty and get a better
description